it's 18-49 William H Bovie leaves his
job at a coffee producer in New York
City to seek his fortune in gold fevered
California but leaving behind the
luxuries of the city
Bovie leaves behind a more expedient cup
of joe out west folks are still buying
their coffee beans green roasting the
beans at home then grinding them with a
hand cranked all before actually brewing
them Bovie builds California's first
coffee mill packaging and selling pretty
roasted beans and in a moment of vision
he takes the process one step farther
making his mill the world's first to
grind the already roasted beans on a
large scale then pack them conveniently
into small consumer-friendly tins only a
few years later however Bovie tires of
the coffee business and sells his shares
of the company to a young employee James
folder folder changes the name and grows
the company to a nationwide brand
jump-starting a race to find the
quickest easiest way to that morning
caffeine fix for the 64% of Americans
that drink coffee daily an expedient cup
is practically essential